hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on monster on our world
again for another video I normally got
its bet it's almost been like an entire
year right then or like two minutes but
today we're gonna be talking about how
to get the butterfly outfit for your
character as well as the new Pugi bee
outfit which is probably the reason why
you're here because I mean who the [ __ ]
cares everybody want spooky outfits of
course but the best way I found out to
get these is going to be an e quest and
it's going to be in a special arena and
it's the two star quest called VESA pod
and the station
you must be HR 4 or higher and the
objective is to slay 30 VESA pods i
recommend bringing the insect leaves as
you can fly in the air or you can just
shoot from the ballista but beware there
is a bouquet bouquet in the middle of
the arena and will attack you and break
the ballista if you're not careful
but once you've defeated those 30 VESA
pods with ease you will get a
Springfield God it looks kind of like a
book and you can use that to craft the
butterfly armor which is going to
require lots of Springfield guide books
as well as other materials
now this armor set though sadly is in
the low ring so it's really not that
worth it obviously because the star it
is a start to question going to
beginning low-rank e'er although it is
cool to maybe have on hand just in case
maybe if you need to for a specific type
of quest but for these stats it has stun
resistance health boost critical eye
defense boost marathon runner attack
boost and divine blessing it also has
116 defense with most of the resistance
going into Dragon and thunder in the
least of it being in fire and water so
it's not too bad but there are
definitely way better options out there
probably one of the cooler things about
this armor set is the fact that it has
the critical eye which is on me hands
that's probably the only really good
part there is health boost if you need
some extra help and some stun resistance
if you also want that too and some
defense and marathon runner but mostly
the critical eye is the most important
part but if you're in the high-ranked
you obviously know there's way better
options and you probably just put a
decoration on it already be better than
the hands itself other than that there
really isn't much to it but for the
poogie outfit it's basically going to
come with him it is a little bee outfit
looks and a little bumpy really cute pig
butt all you have to do is just go find
him wherever he happens to be and it
should be on him automatically you can
of course change it back to whatever you
wanted if you don't like the outfit or
switch it back to the bee if you if you
maybe second-guess yourself or need that
type of good stuff but it is there if
you want to keep it and I recommend
having it just in case if you want to
customize your poopy a bit more and
that's about it the guys that's going to
be another short
video again I'm making a lot of more of
these Monster Hunter World videos since
the Spring Blossom event is out but to
end the video we're just going to show
the last probably 30 seconds of me
beating the [ __ ] out of the VESA pods
while getting chased by a Pooky Pooky
trying not to get poison damage either
way though that's going to be the end
though guys like the video if you did
enjoy really has helped me out subscribe
if you're new I got another guide about
the previous one with the ignition grate
sorry if you want to check that out as
well as a bunch of solo guides a monster
hunter and I'm gonna be doing more stuff
regarding the spring blossom event there
is a rework or there's a rerelease on
some of the events that are already out
that have been out for the past weeks
but I'm going to be talking about those
and doing those over again just in case
people were not familiar with them my
two most recent videos are going to be
on screen like I said one of them it
should be about the cool helmet which is
also another one in the type of in this
event and the next one is also the
ignition great sword if you want to
check that out really would be
appreciated if you check those two out
but that guys hope we have a great
yesterday enjoyed that event and peace
out
[Music]